[Music]
hello my name is matt lacroix marketing
manager for
massey ferguson and heston by massey
ferguson head equipment today i want to
talk to you about the difference between
a rotary rake
and a wheel rake so on the main part of
the field we had really thick hay
not huge deal when you come down here on
the light end of the field
you can see here with the v-rake what
happens
so you start ending up with two
different windrows unless you adjust
your v-rake now nobody wants to get out
and have to do that all the time
and when you have this uneven windrow
almost two different windrows
what ends up happening is you're feeding
your baler unevenly whether it be a
round baler or a small square like we're
using out here today
now on your rotary rake over here you
can see that when you get down to the
smaller lighter crop part of the field
you're gonna have one
solid windrow and you can see the
difference now the good thing about a
rotary rake is
the crop continues to dry out
while it's in the windrow with a wheel
rake it makes a roping action
tying all the crop together it doesn't
allow it to dry out
with a rotary rake you can also bail a
little bit faster
with a small square like we're using
here today with a rotary rate you can
bale
about a mile an hour faster now yes
rotary rakes do have a little bit extra
cost
up front but you'll make it back in
quality of hay
amount of drying time in the windrow and
also in fuel savings because you can get
through the field faster when you're
baling
so this is the massey ferguson rotary
rake and you can see how
nice it picks up the crop and it leaves
a nice fluffy windrow
this one's 12 feet so you can make one
pass down one pass back
a total raking width of 24 feet and now
you see our v-rate running here this is
a tin wheel
and you can see the way it grabs the
crop and brings it around in the
almost rope-like action this windrow was
made by our rotary rake
our rk series this happened to be made
by a 12 foot version
one thing i did talk about earlier was
how fluffy the windrow is and it
continues the drying process
you can see inside this windrow the crop
is still able to get some airflow
through there and dry down
so this was made with our 10-wheel
v-rake now inside this windrow
you'll see more of the crop is trying to
come up when i'm picking up
the other one just picked up real fluffy
but this one's one to pick up more
down through the crop so one thing
that'll happen when you get into longer
crops
say really heavy rye or bermuda
it will start trying to grab the windrow
into your pickup
and pull it because it's in a rope
fashion down through here
now there is very little drying process
happening at the bottom of this
windrow because it's all wound together
i hope this demonstrates the value of a
rotary rake versus a v-rake
and what it can do on your operation for
more information please see your local
massey ferguson and hesston by madison
ferguson dealer
or visit massey ferguson.us